this is the Jocko underground podcast
it's number 26.
you got Echo Charles here
for his commentary
the hand me Jocko willink uh I come
across things from time to time and
I know for a little bit while remember
we dipped into some psychological
experiments and whatnot a little bit
it's good to understand show you some
stuff about human nature there's usually
a bit more more to the story than you
would initially think
there was one that kind of caught my eye
I was doing some reading the other day
and this one was called the monster
study that's what it's called now it
wasn't called that at the time
person named Wendell Johnson I guess a
psychologist named Wendell Johnson 1939
Davenport Iowa conduct this experiment
the experiment was actually ran by a
graduate student her name was Mary Tudor
they took 22 kids
that had some kind of speech impediment
uh actually specific stutter it took him
from an orphanage
and they tried to see if they could help
stuttering kids
by giving them positive feedback how bad
it hurt them if they gave them negative
feedback and if they took normal kids
what it would do to normal kids if they
told them they had a speech impediment
and look I'm not going to detail the the
whole experiment but basically you had
two groups
and then there was two subgroups in
those groups yeah group one a and Group
B group 1A and group 1B these were kids
that actually stuttered
and in group 1A they told the kids like
hey
um don't worry you'll outgrow the
stuttering you'll be able to speak even
much better than speaking now don't
worry about what other people say it's
gonna you'll grow out of it no big deal
that's how they treated those kids
um
then in group b they will they would
tell the kids that stuttered
it's gonna get worse this kind of stuff
just evil I mean right kind of just evil
like even when you hear it now that's
why they call it the monster study
so that's where the kids that actually
stuttered
then they had some kids that had normal
speech
and one group of the kids that had
normal speech they said
you know hey you're really eloquent
you're very articulate just that kind of
stuff just treated them gave them praise
the other group
they told them that and I have a little
quote here they had they they told them
that the staff has come to the
conclusion that you have a great deal of
trouble with your speech
you have many of the symptoms of a child
who's beginning to stutter
you must try to stop yourself
immediately use your willpower do
anything to keep from stuttering don't
ever speak unless you can do it right
you see how from name and they give the
name of a kid that had really bad
stuttering
he started the same way as you
and then they told the staff that worked
with these kids just the regular staff
that worked with them that they had that
they were going to study that they were
developing a stutter and so the teachers
actually believed
the same thing and told them to point
out their mistakes when they spoke
and don't allow them to speak unless
they say it correctly and all this stuff
and it had a super negative
um effect on these kids I mean these
poor kids it's freaking awful uh here's
a little this is from Miss Mary Tudor
the graduate student that ran the
experiment she said all of the subjects
showed similar type of speech behavior
during the experimental period a
decrease in verbal output of all six
subjects these are the ones that we're
told
you're gonna stutter that is that they
were reluctant to speak and spoke only
when they were urged to the rate of
speaking was decreased they spoke more
slowly and with greater exactness they
had a tendency to weigh each word before
they said it their length of response
was shorter two younger subjects
responded with one word whenever
possible
they were more self-conscious they
appeared shy and embarrassed in many
situations they accepted the fact there
was something definitely wrong with
their speech every subject reacted to
speech interruptions in the same manner
some hung or in some manner some hung
their heads others gasped and covered
their mouths with their hands others
laughed with embarrassment
in every case the chief the child's
Behavior changed noticeably
and then she concluded in this that
she she her findings supported or their
findings supported the hypothesis that
evaluative labeling can influence
behavior
August 17th um oh then she went back
after these kids were all messed up and
had messed up speech she went back to
the orphanage to try and reverse the
effects Now using like positive language
and after a little while she reported
quote she was unable to provide enough
positive therapy to reverse
the effects
it's freaking horrible right
17 August 2007 the state of Iowa awarded
1.2 million dollars to the children for
lifelong psychological and emotional
scars
it's from The Experience just from this
freaking experiment
uh my point in reading this or talking
about it is be careful what you say to
people especially kids obviously
especially kids but it's everybody you
know what's interesting is I'm around
people when they have to speak a lot
yeah
in front of crowds or if they were going
to present something look while I was in
the military you know I'd have a young
officer that had to present something
for the first time or and my instinct
was always
to not be hyper critical because I
figured that would only hurt them right
saying hey you better not screw this up
or dude you need to speak clear I
wouldn't say that kind of thing
I'd say yeah hey man just just imagine
that you're just briefing you know Fred
there on the front row no big deal just
just be natural you're a good speaker I
would tell them that kind of thing
that was always my instinct now if I had
some time to work with someone I might
sit them down and say Hey listen here's
how you talk let's record it let's look
at it but if it was sort of hey
someone's getting ready to present in 20
minutes or you know tomorrow
I wouldn't get them all amped up and say
you got you you gotta quit saying oh all
the time I wouldn't say that
because it's going to get worse they're
going to lock up brain lock yeah the
Instinct that I had was tell them hey
don't worry about it's no big deal you
know you you know this stuff well oh
yeah that was a good brief it makes a
lot of sense
tell them that kind of thing let their
confidence raise a little bit and
apparently that instinct was good
because the worst thing you can do is
tell them that hey you're going to lock
up
[Music]
just try your best not to lock up like
just whatever you do yeah that's gonna
be you're don't even look professional
up there that kind of thing is just
brain lock
it's weird too how much of this is
specific to speech because speech is a
really specific kind of thing right you
can kind of hear it it's an immediate
feedback loop when you're doing it now
you could say to someone hey don't choke
during the game yeah you know don't
choke when you're taking the shot the
penalty kick I bet that doesn't help
either you know what a penalty kick is
in soccer yeah
it's like a free throw in basketball
except for that in basketball chances
are look can that be the outcome of the
game yes in soccer yeah it's kind of the
outcome of the game if you miss you just
really really really hurt the team so
the coaches you better not miss this so
I guess it's kind of the same there yeah
yeah do your best yeah you make these
all the time no Factor put it in there
so additional pressure probably not good
for a coach for a parent for an employee
for a boss whatever
yeah
yeah I've always I mean I obviously this
explains a lot some of it it kind of
seems obvious just like you're saying
like it was your instinct especially
with like a public speaking situation
where that's one of those ones where
like the more pressure you put on you
the like so obvious that it's gonna be
bad it's worse you know because it seems
like Anyway the good public speakers
they seem real relaxed and loose and
like they don't they're not apprehensive
they're not like caring about every
little thing that's what it like overtly
seems like when you get a a good public
speaker so it seems a little bit obvious
that it's like dang if someone's even a
little bit nervous don't make them more
like don't put them into a situation
where he has to think about more stuff
or be you know more nervous about other
potential things you know it seems
obvious but that's crazy how much how
deep it goes
and then it kind of starts to let kind
of puts you on what he call puts you on
a report as you would say about like to
yourself about if you have kids you know
like dang what what are you saying to
your kids that you don't even realize
you know because a lot of this stuff
you know like every once in a while like
you'll find yourself start a ring yeah
like you'll get frustrated it's like
your own thing but meanwhile the kid is
like receiving everything and it's gonna
have like some result whether you know
it or not kind of a thing and it all
counts it all counts whether you realize
it or not you know it's one of those
things I I remember my dad would
say this and I think I even told you
this before where so I have a twin
brother right
yeah he was born a little bit bigger
than me just a little bit not to any
significant degree but just a little bit
bigger nonetheless yes so he so he's
always been like a half inch taller than
me he's always been um just this much
heavy usually either like he's always
five pounds heavier than me growing up
right it's a young adolescent young man
of today until you found that easy girl
bar well bro you're you're not wrong
here so and but to my dad as far as what
my dad would say he would use that
he didn't mean it my dad is like the
most warm-hearted guy ever if you talk
to him BC yeah BC and but so he didn't
mean it you know he didn't know what he
was doing but he would do this as more
like a tactic to make me
help with chores or finish my dinner or
whatever he'd be like oh yeah
he'd be like Jade's always volunteering
you know and you're not and then he'd be
like look at Jade uh uh eating all his
dinner that's why he's bigger than you
oh man no wonder you found that easy
girl started just getting after it man
you have no idea how right you are so he
he so he would say stuff all the time
and it wasn't it I remember it didn't
bother me that much but I remember
thinking like wow that's like
freaking Jade like yeah he's bigger than
me so it would kind of work is what I'm
saying meanwhile I'd still be smaller
than him he'd always be five pounds
heavier so when I got to be maybe 10 11
12 years old I would secretly like do
push-ups and me and Jada were the kind
where like if you start doing push-ups
you're like you tease him you know like
oh you're trying to do push-ups or
you're trying to be a strong and you
know it's like that like that's a
relationship we had everything it was
all for jokes but you'd kind of feel it
so I'd secretly do push-ups and I'd
secretly do like calf raises and my dad
and my dad
my dad had um these dumbbells because
you know you have random he had a 20 out
of 10. bro bro
I would do that but and then when we hit
like 12 13 14 years old like my chest
was like I was still smaller than him
but my chest had more like development
in it and I was like yeah yeah he was
still bigger though but and then when we
started actually lifting weights because
the you know the football coaches and
they're like hey you guys got to lift
weight so we go lift weights and see
where we're at starting right I could
bench more than him yeah I was like oh
so I got that payoff all because of that
experience for my dad and you know all
this stuff and I just got super
aggressive like compared to him I'm way
more like aggressive like I'll lift
weights more I started Jujitsu like that
kind of stuff and he's just like not
he's more into like you know computers
and all the stuff still athletic dude
yeah for sure but he was introduce you
for a little while yeah but that I mean
let's face it he like you right you ever
rolled with him yeah he's not like he
did it for the fun of it yeah straight
up and it was fine and he did it for the
social part of it or whatever to me
some of the very important benefits of
it by the way but he wasn't into the
competitive element of it you know like
even like and I won't Express this
outwardly that much but inside even when
me and you go or whatever and then
every once in a while like I'll like try
to kill you he doesn't have that like he
won't
really he has it but way less you know
like it's comparatively speaking way
less it's really obvious too what's
weird too is you if you start thinking
about like there's got to be a line that
your dad could have crossed
let's say BC wasn't you know kind of
cool and chill yeah and and it was kind
of like
um why couldn't you be more like your
bro like right yeah well then you become
real resentful and you get a Cain and
able scenario unfolding yeah where
you're just jealous and resentful and
you end up
yeah so there's a there's a good balance
because it's beneficial kind of what BC
did because he did in a lighthearted way
possibly yeah but it's also good to
remember you know I always you know
people asked what's important you know
for kids in Jiu Jitsu it's like make it
fun that's the most important thing make
it fun if it's fun and you read that
book
outliers by Malcolm Gladwell that's what
it is the kids that played hockey that
were at the high end of the age bracket
so they're in there they're they're like
they're like 10 years and 364 days old
at the beginning of the Season someone
else is you know just 10 years and one
day old so you got 364 years of physical
development at age 12. that's a big
difference that kid goes out there and
just dominates on the field and then he
likes it so then he practices more and
the more he practices the better he gets
and now he he gets even better so now he
gets the ball even more he scores more
goals and people raise him up on their
shoulders and it's even more stars it's
like a like a positive circle of
feedback loop yeah
the other end of that is
oh the little scrawny kid gets thrown in
with the bigger kids get knocked down
gets you know doesn't get the ball
doesn't get played doesn't get playing
time he's not gonna practice well he
might get motivated sure Michael Jordan
did right Michael Jordan didn't make the
team they just practiced and trained
until he made it but that's uh that
could be an outcome
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen
go to Jocko underground.com And
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you just email assistance
at Jocko underground.com and we'll get
you taken care of until then we will see
you mobilized
Underground